we had a very good discussion and it was
concrete and candid and as you noticed
quite short we focused on Europe's two
most important challenges boosting
investment and the situation at our
eastern borders today do rypien council
called for a european found for
strategic investment to be set up
urgently we want to foster better
investment climate in Europe the leaders
also agreed to continue ensuring sound
public finances to push for structural
reforms and to deliver on our plans for
an energy union trade but the regulation
and for the digital economy the aim of
jean-claude Juncker the author of this
plan and the main person tonight is to
mobilize 315 billion euro between 2015
and 2017 to achieve these leaders want
the fans to be in place by next June
also the european investment bank got
the green light to start doing its own
part from january on in the weeks ahead
specific legislation will be discussed
but today leaders gave the direction and
set the timeline it is for private
investors to back the most promising
project the situation in Ukraine remains
dramatic and dynamic and requires an
immediate response that's why you have
just discussed giving financial support
to you crying we are sending a strong
signal on our readiness to do so we also
talked about Russia's policy towards its
neighbors and our strategic response we
must go beyond being reactive and
defensive Europeans we must regain our
self-confidence and realize our own
strength